what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals in this one we're
actually picking up in the aftermath of
the conclusion of issue number five
which is kind of funny because in the
reading order they say this one actually
comes before issue number five and it
doesn't quite make any sense this comes
after but the thing about this is that
where you did have the progenitor
Celestial that basically annihilated
everybody there are some who made it out
alive specifically those individuals who
were actually inside of the progenitor
Celestial itself of course Iron Man Jean
Gray those individual guys now the thing
about this is that it really is in the
most true definition a coming together
of the Avengers the X-Men and the
eternals and some of these guys have
actually been both for example Wolverine
has been both a X-Man and an Avenger
he's never been an eternal but
nonetheless right their goal here is the
same as it was before to find some way
to bring the progenitor Celestial down
except this time it's not the same right
previously when they lost a Strike Team
it was to try to find a weak point and
destroy that weak point obviously that
failed because of the fact that they
were dealing with a being of just cosmic
power so somehow getting inside of it
and trying to find a way to deactivate
it or end it from the inside out is
seemingly the only way to pull that off
now the irony behind all this and this
is one of those things where Marvel's
kind of changing it either for the story
or because it's just the future nature
of things is when they get inside of the
celestial itself so the interior or the
insides of a Celestial have been
depicted in different ways in Marvel
Comics in different instances they've
said that celestials are just beings
composed of pure energy on the inside in
other instances celestials are actually
beings you can enter into the reality
here and this current depiction of the
inside of a Celestial has kind of been
this way ever since Mr Sinister had
first entered into the dreaming
Celestial in Marvel Comics back in the
day so it's kind of the standard they're
going with and will likely continue with
for quite some time but the important
thing here is that once they're in there
they start to realize that the celestial
literally has an antibody system right
it has what amounts to human white blood
cells insides of it or organisms inside
of it that are designed to basically
Force out any kind of external Factor
that's not supposed to be there in this
instance those individual guys now the
most logical question to ask here is if
this is a being of unfathomable power
why doesn't it just incinerate them
while they're inside and the answer to
that is comic book Logic the necessity
of being able to tell the story so what
this does is of course it leads to the
X-Men the eternals The Avengers all kind
of bailing out as fast as they can but
these different antibodies end up
adhering themselves to Tony Stark and
that's when Tony Stark goes to this
really really cool process because he
almost kind of finds himself in this
cave so to speak and sees the body of ho
Jensen and then he's immediately
attacked by the Iron Man suit mark one
right like the first suit of armor that
he ever made as primitive as it was
comparing to the kind of stuff that he
has now and it's one of those things
where he's sort of taunted by it right
where even the suit goes as far as to
say look at your legacy Tony look at
what you've done you keep building suits
people keep dying I am the end result of
your efforts to build some being out
there that can really be a testament to
what you're capable of and I've
annihilated pretty much all the
superheroes that you know your legacy
Tony Stark is a legacy of death and
ultimately it's one of those things
where Tony Stark initially brushes it
off but then he starts getting these
hard-on Visions like the death of
Captain America and that's one of the
cool moments here because this is in a
lot of ways kind of The Life and Times
of Tony Stark or this sort of depiction
of the people that Tony Stark has in
some form or fashion led to the death of
not not directly but the thing about
this is it's kind of a reliving that
moment where even Captain America pops
up and it's like I could be dead already
I could be dead again and you may as
well have killed me and it's really just
this instance where this Celestial is
putting Iron Man through the paces and
saying you created me you're the one
that frankensteined me together it was
your idea this kind of goes directly
into Christopher cantwell's Iron Man run
which was just a phenomenal story but
basically it was a story where Tony
Stark ended up becoming what was called
the iron God where he basically got
galactus's power but for a time Tony
Stark was the most powerful being in the
universe outside of like the super high
level Cosmic entities right eternity
Infinity those guys but in that story he
had actually killed James Rhodes and
pretty much all of his allies at least
as far as his uh space Friends team but
he's kind of taunted by that right like
look at your legacy Tony Stark you
killed me right James Rhodes kind of
appearing as War Machine and of course
he ended up kind of setting him back but
then he's basically shown or kind of
presented with Ragnarok right now when
it comes to Marvel Comics Ragnarok
appears in two different forms there's
the Ragnarok event which is basically
the death of all the asgardians right
the foretold prophecy of how the
asgardians will die and then there was
Ragnarok in the form of the Thor robot
that Iron Man had created using a strand
of Thor's hair and kind of cloned him
and created a sort of cyborg in the
process but during the original Civil
War event when Ragnarok was originally
presented to the world it killed Bill
Foster and so Tony Stark is kind of
confronted with that like your leg is
see it's one of death and destruction
your legacy is one where people end like
literally it says you tried it with me
and you saw what happened you never
learn but the truth right now a God was
needed you were the iron God and you
gave it up if you were still the iron
God you could have fought this Celestial
returned all to life undone all whoa if
only you had held it together for a few
more weeks now one of the things that I
also want to point out here is that for
these different circumstances that Tony
Stark is being presented with Tony Stark
is presenting himself in a humble way
he's not ingratiating himself but he's
accepting his faults and accepting his
his failures like in response to the
idea of him having been the iron God
having had the power of Galactus his
response is it was too much for me and
it's too much for anyone and even here
it's kind of stated you're right you
could have never held it together men
like you are slowly killing the planet
at least this cuts to the chase you're
an addict always will be you're off news
and now you're addicted to saving the
world bigger risk bigger High how fine
can you cut it eventually you were
always going to push it too close that
it's really one of those things where
it's like it's always he's always going
from one addiction to another addiction
right it's the nature of Tony Stark in
Marvel Comics and so it's one of those
things where following that he's
presented with the Incredible Hulk this
of course is a homage to the original
sin's story for those of you guys who
never read that one of the things that
had gone on there is that there was a
the original project that had led to
Bruce Banner becoming the Incredible
Hulk was actually a joint venture
between Tony Stark and banner and I'm a
little fuzzy on the details but the long
and short of it is that seemingly Tony
Stark was aware of what was going on
that basically this gamma explosion
could potentially have disastrous
results and could actually lead to
something of you know something like
this happening to Banner or at least
affecting him in some way but because of
that when Banner had learned that truth
he blamed Iron Man for the fact that he
became Hulk in the first place that's
what this is it's kind of the really
Iron Man being Revisited by all his sins
but it's also Iron Man having to come to
terms in his battle against the entirety
of the superhero Community right to face
his own demons is to face the superhero
Community because time and time again
Iron Man has done nothing but in a lot
of ways fail the superhero community and
so what ends up happening is one of the
things that he's forced to endure is the
death of his parents right watching his
parents die but the celestial even says
that it says hey some bad news here with
Whitney Frost shaped exceptions you're
attracted to parental figures who
provide a strong moral compass because
yours is absolutely whacked I wonder
where it comes from and the reality here
is that it comes from Howard and Maria
Stark Maria Stark kind of tried to do
her best to a degree but Howard Stark
was exceedingly hard on Tony and it was
one of those things where it was always
like you can be better you have to be
better now this is where the the history
gets a little murky because if you go
back and you read Kieran gillen's run uh
the secret origin of Tony Stark you
learned that Tony's actually adopted by
Howard and Maria and their biological
son is Arno who is every bit as smart as
Howard wanted him to be due to some
genetic modifications and tampering the
whole Arnold Stark thing just kind of
seems to have taken a background and
just sort of been wiped Away by time
more or less in Marvel Comics they just
haven't really told any stories about
him but the important distinction here
is that in place of Arno Tony was raised
by Howard and whether or not Arno still
even a part of the equation the fact
remains Howard was always hard on Tony
he was very much a perfectionist you can
be better so be better right being like
like trying your best is not good enough
be the best right Like Only Fools make
mistakes and so it's one of those things
where in the end you have this amazing
realization because Tony Stark kind of
comes clean in terms of why he even does
what he does in the first place he says
he says I always hoped it was an
accident or an assassination that people
claim that it was or that Mom and Dad
faked their deaths or something that's
what orphans do we make up stories that
give a bit of drama right they get give
a reason to why this happened but in the
end it was just a car crash people die
for no reason at all and in response the
celestial says you are mistaken there
was a reason they died because a machine
failed them if only they had been in a
better machine a machine that could have
protected them in this hell world and
that is the source of why Tony Stark
does what he does because in the end he
initially tries to blow off the entirety
of the of the celestial and saying like
I've got work to do right I don't really
have time for for any of this nonsense
and the response of the celestial is to
basically appear as Howard Stark and to
say people die son I was a terrible
father we wanted you so badly and then
when we had you I still wasn't great we
did a number on you and then we left you
we had so much we wanted to tell you and
share and show yet you keep on going he
says I wouldn't have most people
wouldn't have a broken machine keeps on
taking anyway you're too hard on
yourself you pass I I couldn't be
prouder of you because it's Tony Stark
confessing to the celestial that's why
he does what he does it's why he builds
such Advanced machines that's why he
builds Iron Man suits that's why he goes
on these crazy campaigns from time to
time where he always has to be better
because it's one of those retroactive
things if he builds a better Iron Man
suit this time he can save his mom and
dad right building the most advanced
Iron Man suit he can possibly can is
like basically building a better car so
his mom and dad wouldn't have died he's
Chasing Ghosts there's no way for him to
keep that from happening I mean I guess
maybe he could invoke time travel but
that's never really been a major part of
his story that's been explored and
honestly I'd be kind of curious to see
what would happen if it was but the
reality here is the death of Howard and
Maria Stark played a significant role in
The Life and Times of Tony because them
dying in a car crash was just that and
so once it's all said and done he kind
of emerges from this quote-unquote
antibody cocoon if you want to call it
that but basically brought about by the
eternals and the the X-Men and the rest
of the Avengers and so on and so forth
and the thing about it is that he talks
about how he met his dad and his dad
told him like I'm proud of you you've
always become the person that I thought
you would and that sort of thing so even
if only on an emotional level
reconciling with his own father and
where it's initially brushed off by Mr
Sinister the response of Iron Man is no
like you don't get it it was testing me
and if it's still testing me it's still
testing us and if it's still testing us
it means we have a chance to win we have
a chance to Stave off the destruction of
the planet it's when that clock reaches
zero when the hand gets to midnight then
that's when we panic but for right now
we're five minutes from Annihilation
which means we have five minutes to save
every living thing on Earth with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace